what do you think is next like if you
look at the cell phone you look at
technology and the integration in our
lives what do you think is the next step
I don't think people understand
understand understand to understand what
the [ __ ] is actually coming every single
person here besides the health and
well-being of their family and money
values time as we become more busy we
start valuing time tremendously when
you're looking at video it is taking up
your time audio is incredibly passive
passive passive passive tone for
everybody who kind of passively consumes
pay triple attention listening to
something in the first five minutes when
you wake up and getting out of bed and
getting ready is information that you're
consuming that you're not looking at
your phone because you're in the shower
like imagine brushing your teeth in the
morning remembering that you need socks
and saying in your bathroom hey Google
hey Apple hey Alexa hey Facebook or
whatever else comes out because the next
search engine is voice and Alexa's ahead
hey Alexa buy my soap Alexa play my
daily briefs Alexa who's Kobe Bryant
Alexa play I'm still standing by Elton
John hey Alexa when does England play in
the World Cup that exists because I know
that's the next landscape of attention
but I genuinely believe that voice is a
platform is gonna be a much bigger deal
in entertainment and utility in commerce
instead of predicting I just recognize
that voice is working that podcast
consumption is unknown it's just being
first faster and making a bet in the
early indicators instead of yes so it
feels like I'm predicting the future but
I'm taking innovation that's happening
around me
I'm deploying it against my own reality
at that time my bet was that we would
pick convenience over history because I
only care about one thing what one thing
the end customer we will always pick
convenience over everything it's all
about time savings so over one because
it saves you time prime wins because it
saves you time anything that saves us
time right you guys want everything
right now both that's right always
anything that slow [ __ ] like slow
internet is like devastating right like
speed we've become addicted to speed so
I think voice is speed even if you we
have your phone right here if you can
say Alexa or Google or Apple what's my
what is my schedule today and the house
is talking to you it's just faster than
taking your phone hitting turning on
it's just friction and we hate friction
Alexa and voice is the future of a
frictionless world it is going to
explode there are things that you're
doing now that will blow you away that
you'll be doing only in voice like I
genuinely think I'm gonna poke my head
out of the shower three times per shower
saying tell babban to meet me on 19th
Street it's gonna be unbelievable speed
utility and I think for example texting
will decline because it's gonna be
faster to say it and get that person to
know the information then it is to grab
the phone and you because I know in 2026
right in eight years when all of you
realize how much better that is
it's going to matter hey Alexa by this I
mean that's it
I just bought government so like what do
people think is coming Baker
call AJ Vaynerchuk calling edge Vader
puck see recalls our last name Boehner
[ __ ]
[Music]